Narrator: This is Tim Kimmel,
the supervising sound
editor on "Game of Thrones."
Not only is he the voice behind
some of the show's
wights and White Walkers,
but through a process
of mixing and layering,
he helped create the stuff of nightmares
for the people of Westeros
and viewers at home.
Warning: Spoilers are coming.
Kimmel has been working on the show
since the start of season three.
In fact, he won an Emmy for his work
in the episode "Hardhome."
He and the sound team
had to bend a few rules
to get them to make the
sound in the first place.
For example, creatures
like this with no skin
and likely no vocal chords
probably shouldn't be able
to make any sound at all.
- Well, if it comes at you quietly,
it doesn't really have the same impact,
especially some of these
straight-up skeletons.
They don't have vocal chords.
So, you know, we sometimes
would try to lean away
from the wights that were so
rotted away with no flesh.
We talked about the sounds
that they'd be making.
They'd have vocal chords
that are kind of shredded.
Narrator: The sounds they did give them
came from a variety of places, and Kimmel
has an especially personal
connection with the wights.
Some of the sounds the wights made
actually came directly from him.
The sound, as he describes it,
came from the back of his throat.
After enough distorting
in the editing room,
it sounds more like this.
You could also hear him doing the sound
of Wun Wun the giant.
- I'll admit, I'm a big metalhead.
I grew up in the '80s, so
it is sort of a metal yell.
It's a (roaring) kind of yell.
Narrator: And with the wight giant,
they used the same sound elements
but with a grittier feel to it.
But it's not just Kimmel's voice in there.
If you listen carefully, you
might hear some animal sounds.
Some of the most vicious
sounds coming from the wights
were actually sounds of dogs
that were manipulated and tweaked enough
that you couldn't tell they
were dog sounds originally.
And that wight that Jon Snow
smuggled into King's Landing
to show Cersei in season seven
was actually making the
sounds of a bear cub.
A lot of work happens in postproduction
to make sure this...
will sound like this.
More on this scene in a bit.
After years of work, many sounds are saved
in a vast digital library and reused.
However, the sounds they used
and the sounds the creatures
make would still change
depending on the scene.
- It has to do with what they
look like, what they're doing.
As they're just walking
or slowly attacking,
they don't make much
sounds, but as they start
to really attack, the
more aggressive ones,
we'll go with a more aggressive sound.
A lot of it has to be story-driven.
If there's one that's right
on top of a main character
that you're worried is gonna kill them,
we'll find the most
aggressive one we can find
and really make the viewer
worry, "Oh no, this is it."
It helps compel that
story a little bit more.
Narrator: The more
aggressive the creatures,
the more aggressive the
sounds they use will get.
You can't talk about
the sounds of the wights
and White Walkers without
discussing how they move.
Much of the movements
are done through Foley,
a process in which real objects are used
to create sounds of living creatures
interacting with the world.
When it comes to their
movement, they start bare bones,
literally, as a lot of the
wights are nothing but skeletons.
They used real bones and ceramic objects,
but you'll also hear a lot
of other sounds at play
in any given scenes where
the undead army is scurrying around.
- A lot of those wights were soldiers,
and they'd have some armor
still hanging off of them
or some leather hanging off of them,
so we also incorporate that
and incorporate some of the
flesh sounds a little bit
and a little bit of cloth.
Just so it's not just bones, just to,
it gives it a little more depth.
Narrator: The further
the show has moved along,
the more wights they've had to deal with.
When Kimmel first started
working on the show,
they were making sound for
just a handful of them.
On the other hand, the
Battle of Winterfell
saw the North face off against an army
of thousands of wights and White Walkers.
During this battle, they were dealing
with hundreds of different sounds at once.
One of the biggest challenges
was capturing sound
that really gave the audience the feel
of the scope of this army.
As the North's army waited
for the undead to approach,
it had to be very quiet at first
and then get progressively
louder as they crept closer
and closer to the city's walls.
- You had to get as big as
you can for that first wave,
so it just feels huge, but
what was tricky in the shot
was that first wave hits, and then you get
to a reaction shot of the
other part of the army,
and then there's a second
wave that comes in,
so if you go too big on the first wave,
you don't feel the second
wave, so you had to find
a way to feel big but still
have room to get even bigger.
Narrator: But surprisingly,
the hardest moments
for Kimmel and his team
came not when dealing
with armies but when dealing
with a single wight on screen.
Back to that scene where Jon
brings a wight into King's Landing.
- Usually when these wights are going,
there's a lot of stuff to hide behind.
There's other battle things,
and so it's not as out in the open,
so you can kinda do more with it
and get away with little cheats,
but this thing was on its own.
It needed to be scary.
Narrator: The thing that made the wights
and White Walkers truly
terrifying throughout their run
wasn't just the sounds they made
but also the ones they didn't make.
In an early appearance in
season two, you can hear
a White Walker speak in
Skroth, their native tongue.
This was then abandoned
in later appearances.
Kimmel also pointed out
that in early appearances,
the Night King would open
his mouth and show his teeth.
- I think they just found
him more intimidating
to just be there with a
straight look on his face.
He's just standing there confident.
You don't know what he's gonna
do or what he's capable of.
Narrator: Sometimes, no sound
is the scariest sound of all.